this is what is considered an
olympic-style recurve
this is the modern version of the old
long bows it's only bow that's allowed
in the games this setup right here is
what you would see a shooting at the
Olympics with our sights they're
adjustable up and down we don't have any
magnification but we do have a sight
that we could put in the middle in
aimless
we shoot 70 meters 77 yards we're
hitting a circle this big and if you
want to move a little metal you don't
miss that these are V bars and a
stabilizer that helps us hold steady
less torque you can see mine new
stabilizers that came out the carbon
blades they're very aerodynamic they're
kind of like swords and that's really
gonna help us in London you know mass
weight just this is probably eight to 10
pounds when I'm at full draw there's 53
pounds of tension on these three fingers
from the string everything on our bows
is really custom because not everyone
shoots 53 pounds a lot of people shoot
50 48 somewhere in there but I shoot on
the upper end of most of the guys the
most personal piece of gear we have is a
finger tab this is what protects our
fingers from the string and our bows are
getting faster which is huge but at the
same times all of our bows got faster
our arrows have stayed the same I shoot
from 8:00 to 8:30 in the morning until
five o'clock in the afternoon with a
lunch break six days a week